that's really applicable um we keep
seeing
cities like rochester new york daniel
prude and philadelphia with
walter wallace where police were called
to handle
a individual experiencing mental health
issues and the situation escalated
and often ended in death and despair
while this session is specifically about
self-care
let's just face it directly what should
city leaders do to help
uh counsel and help help address these
kinds of
issues as they escalate and actually
the fact of police may not even have the
expertise
to deal with these any advice
well they have to train police one of
the things we did in philadelphia we had
a great partnership i was a
the mental health commissioner and had a
great partnership with the city's
police commissioner and you know over
the time that i was
in my position we trained about 40
of the the police department in
something called
crisis intervention training or cit uh
it's done all around the country
um but you know we what we did was to
not only train
officers on how to uh recognize when
someone might be
having a mental health uh emergency and
how to
work through those and actually the what
the way we train
uh officers is on de-escalation uh
that's the way you you manage through
those
those kinds of situations and uh giving
them the tools to
to do that made a tremendous difference
in
their uh ability to respond to these
when i first took my
uh position back in 2004 in the city
we were having um fairly regularly
people with mental health who are
experiencing mental health crises
being shot sometimes killed by uh police
um almost every three or four months
something was coming up
and i would say the last six seven years
that i was in my position
we had no known uh shooting uh what does
that tell us that tells us that
this is not an intractable problem this
is something that we
have the technology and the research and
the the knowledge to fix what it takes
is
city leaders saying we're we're going to
make this a priority
we're going to make sure that we have
the resources to train our officers how
to
deal with these issues and you have to
not only train the officers but put into
place
a system so you know if you called 9-1-1
the the people responding knew that
if they thought that this was a
psychiatric emergency that they were
going to deploy
officers who were trained uh and then
there were also
people from the mental health crisis
community that would also respond to
those so
that combination of training and
creating a system can make a huge
difference in saving lives and really
helping officers through those
really difficult situations
so um ace if you had to uh give
two points of uh advice as we go into
the thanksgiving holiday for
municipal officials what would it be
just two things well i
i think it's really important to
understand the the
importance of our mental health it's
just a part of us it's and
we have to normalize it i think it's
important for city
leaders to talk about mental health i
think it's important for people to know
some of the the strategies like you know
we talk a lot about
um making sure that you are socially
connected we say that because there's a
lot of research that shows that
if you are socially connected you're
going to do better psychologically and
health wise
uh we talk about reducing the amount of
media we talk about
uh doing things to manage the stress
levels that we
are experiencing like exercising and you
know taking care of ourselves physically
all of those things go into us being
psychologically healthy
and as we go into these holidays we
really have to prioritize
our health and the health of our
families and so
that's going to be difficult because
that may mean that we're not being
physically close
but we can still do things to overcome
that and be
socially connected so on behalf of the
national league of cities i'd like to
uh thank you so much for spending this
time with us today
and personally i just like to say uh i
appreciate you so much and
want our delegates who's attending the
conference to know
that he's been my psychologist for over
41 years
and i still that's a tough job
i i have to say that's a tough job but
you've been a great friend
and a great leader and a role model so i
appreciate that
all right love you tell claudine i said
hi okay you take care
uh thank you to close out today we have
one final
speaker joining us a late addition to
our agenda but
an important one to do our official
introduction
i'd like to welcome back to our virtual
stage
nlc president joe buscaino
take it away joe thanks so much claire's
i was hoping to
hear dr evans some of the um
the experience you all had in college
but maybe not we might have to lose our
audience
but thank you so much clarence and dr
evans so um such an important
conversation
for all of us to have okay colleagues we
have one
final speaker to hear from today
now as you all know last year at city
summit nlc committed
to you that we would ensure that
candidates in the 2020 presidential
election
understood our federal priorities and
more importantly the importance of
partnering with
local leaders we were proud to get
commitments from
nearly every major presidential
candidate to our
leading together agenda and three weeks
ago
as we all saw we saw the largest voter
turnout in our country's
history and our country selected
their candidate to lead us for the next
four years
so nlc immediately began to connect with
the transition team to uplift our
priority for the first 100 days
of the new administration including
covid relief
infrastructure workforce development
housing and homelessness and reducing
gun violence
this afternoon we have the great honor
of
hearing directly from our next president
please join me in welcoming the man who
started his political career career in
1970 on the new castle
county council went on to be senator for
the great state
of delaware and for 36 years and finally
as we all know served as the 47th
vice president of the united states help
me welcome
president-elect joe biden
hey everybody i hope that all of you and
your families and loved ones are
keeping safe during these hard days for
our nation
we're facing the darkest days of this
pandemic and our economy is still in
crisis
and recovering much too slowly in my
view we're we're experiencing a long
overdue reckoning on racial justice
and we have to take serious actions to
address the existential threat of
climate change
american cities are on the front lines
on all of these crises
you know you are the people in this
country uh
look to first for your leadership your
guidance towns cities
larger cities you know i know how hard
it's been
you know when we did the recovery act
back when
and when we first came in office i dealt
with
thousands of the folks in your in small
cities
and big cities and you are the place
where people go
their quality of life depends more on
what you're doing than anything else and
i know
how hard it's been covet is straining
your health care systems
burning out your healthcare providers
essential workers are putting their
lives and their health at risk
to keep your communities running but
you're not getting the support you need
to be able to keep paying your teachers
your police officers your firefighters
your first responders
providing them ppe keeping everyone safe
you know it's if we and the congress has
passed the money
it's passed the money that was designed
to do this
and it's not coming forward i know it
must be frustrating
yet in the face of these challenges
you've all stepped up
i want to thank you for being there for
your communities for the families who
are grieving and lost loved ones you're
there
for the folks who are worried about
they're going to be able to pay their
rent or
find their mortgage payment and all the
proud americans who are seeking food
support
i've seen it you've seen those those
lines in your own cities
thousands of people lining up for the
first time in their lives
first time in their lives needing food
for thanksgiving
needing food day to day i want you to
know that my administration will have
your back i promise you
and it didn't matter whether your city
supported me or didn't support me i
meant what i said
there are no red cities there are no
blue cities they're only american cities
american states period i really mean
that
these are american challenges we have to
meet them with one country
as one country not as i said as red and
blue states but the united states
and vice president-elect harris and i
are committed to being real partners to
you
so we can coordinate a real nationwide
response
to these crises so i want to thank you
all for what you're doing
for your leadership comfort and support
you'll continue to provide for americans
as we face this pandemic
i know that our best days still lie
ahead i really believe that
and as president i'm going to work with
all of you
to deliver to deliver for the american
people and i really mean that
like i said you know you're right on the
front lines
people probably literally are knocking
on some of your doors
your doors you city managers
city mayors council persons
i want to thank you all you really are
doing a job
and you're not asking anybody when they
ask for help whether they're democrat
republican independent
you're stepping up i promise you i will
do that
and you have a seat at my table in the
white house
when i am sworn in i genuinely mean it
i genuinely mean it i wish all of
you and yours a safe and healthy
thanksgiving
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you so much for that inspiring
refreshing message president-elect biden
your commitment to true partnership
with local leaders is so important and
we at national league of cities we're
excited about
your appointment for julie rodriguez the
inter-government affairs director
we'll be working hand-in-hand with her
thank you again sir and as
you know why uh president-elect
biden taking the time to join us today
is is extra special
because it's his birthday so happy
birthday president-elect
biden so all right my friends we have
come to the conclusion
of our final general session
but we're not finished be sure now to
join us
at our annual business meeting where we
will elect our new officers
and adopt our municipal policy guide for
the coming year
if you are registered as your city or
state municipal league's voting delegate
please make sure to join us in the
annual business meeting for voting
delegates listed under
my agenda but if you're not a voting
delegate we invite you to attend a live
stream of the meeting that's
open to the public which can be found on
the full agenda tab
it has been truly an honor to have you
all join us
virtually can't wait to see you all
again in march
may god bless and protect you thank you
so much for joining us and
looking forward to seeing you at the biz
annual business meeting thanks again